- [Man] Sometimes when you play
in the clouds too much,
there's no ideas in the clouds.
To me all the great
ideas come from the dirt.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] Marcus? Po?
Let me know.
- Yeah, you're okay to
wait a couple days, right?
- [Gary] Yeah, I knew
what you're doing.
I didn't do that for, I did
that make the money work.
- That's why I might look at
other guys that aren't good
might but might make money work.
Okay, no worries.
- [India] (inaudible)
Mark Evans.
- [Gary] The 6-60,
I want to really pound it.
- Okay.
- That video, do you know how
many people in the last fucking
week have come up to me
and said it changed...?
We need every 40 to 60-year-old
on Facebook to see it.
Get it done.
- Yeah.
- Get it done ASAP
and I'll give you.
Get a captioned and
I'll give you the copy for it.
Let's get it done ASAP.
(slow music)
Interesting day.
I'm actually feeling a little
more lethargic than normal.
My energy is little down.
Mark and I, Mark and I this
is a big day for Mark and I.
We had breakfast together,
we had another meeting together,
we have another meeting,
we're now going to client.
- [Mark] A lot of M.E. time.
- A lot of M.E. time.
Mark Evans.
We'll see, I'm sure we'll pick
up some momentum as we go along.
Got some stuff done.
Didn't get anybody I wanted
my fantasy baseball
wire transactions.
On the waiver wire so a
little disappointed in that.
It's a beautiful day.
That's got my
energy up a little bit.
This dude's
hair's got me excited.
We'll see.
All it takes is one thing
to get the momentum go.
(slow hip hop music)
I think it is the
opposite traits of having
the confidence and the bravado
to think that I could run a
business of that size while
having the humility and the
patience to know the reason
VaynerMedia's successful is
because I've been running it
day in and day out, 15 hour days
sessions working very hard and
patiently over the last 5 to 7
years so I think that, you know,
I don't think I can walk into
any business right now that's
large in an industry I've
never done before fashion,
selling cars, whatever it may be
but I know that over a
five or ten year period
I would learn it by doing
hands-on experience and
then become very successful in it.
I think it comes down to the
confidence in actually doing the
work and doing
the tried and true.
I can't be successful
by just saying it.
I have to be willing to put
in the work and I think I'm
willing to put in the work and
have shown myself that if I put
in the work I have the
talent of learning
on the job and over a
period of time
becoming successful.
(slow hip hop music)
Pleasure, real good.
How are you?
Hey man.
- Chris.
- Chris, Gary.
- What's good, man?
- Hustling baby.
- Heard.
- You?
- I'm blessed, man.
Just got off of work.
- Good weekend?
- Great weekend, man.
Had a lot of good digital shit
going with that bird man clip.
- Oh yeah?
- You didn't see it?
- I didn't see it.
- Put some respeck on my name.
- I'm gonna check it.
- Out of the top 15 trending
toppers we was like 13 of them.
- [Gary] Get the
fuck out of here.
- Yeah, it was like the
Breakfast Club, Charlamagne,
my two co-hosts,
Angeline, DJ NV.
- What did he say?
- Nothing.
It was literally like
2:30 in the morning.
He came in there he said all
three of you mother fuckers are
going to stop playing with my
name, learn to respect my name
but he was saying
respect like R-E-S-P-E-K.
(laughter)
It was like he sat down
and did this I ain't gonna
say no more.
- [Charlamagne] It is a
privilege and an honor to have
the guy that we have here today
he is a man who has become one
of my favorite
corporate thug motivators.
Goes by the name
of Gary Vaynerchuk.
Gary did I pronounce
Vaynerchuk, right?
- Yeah, you drilled it.
- [Charlamagne] Ok.
- I'm impressed.
- [Charlamagne]
What's happening, brother?
- Things are phenomenal, man.
How are you?
Anything I talk about is for
people that are complaining.
Meaning when I talk about hustle
and I talk about work a lot
it's the one thing that I think
is controllable that if you're
sitting now and listening and
you're complaining you're not
happy of where you are that
there's a lot of things that
I like to talk to
those people about.
- DRock did the clouds and--
- [Gary] And the dirt.
- the dirt video.
- [Gary] Yep.
- That was his idea for
you to do that, right?
- [Gary] Yep. Yep.
DRock emailed me a couple times
and finally I said yes so we
made video called
"Clouds and Dirt".
- [Charlamagne] Explain the
philosophy of clouds and dirt.
I love it.
- It's macro and micro so
I want to buy the Jets,
I've got all these big ideas,
I think I know where
the world's going.
And I'll fucking wake up
at three in the morning
and fucking answer email.
See what people don't understand
is that the dirt is so important
because unless you have actually
have the skills your reputation
or what you did the day before
or who your mama is isn't
gonna impact your success.
Your success is going to be
predicated by the dirt and the
dirt is a mixture of having
the work ethic to get your hands
dirty and then the
experience predicated from
actually doing the work.
If you're not working on your
craft, if you got too fancy to
keep doing your thing.
You lose.
It's why love comedians that
still go to small clubs and still
work on, Seinfeld in his prime
just going to bullshit clubs in
the middle America and working
on his craft, that's a winner.
People that play acoustic or
people that just go and
battle who are
hip-hop artists. It's dirt.
It's never getting too fancy to
get away from what got you there
in the first place.
- [Ron] Exactly.
- That's how people lose.
- [Ron] Yep.
- It's like you know when in
hip-hop somebody gets big,
and I'm sure you've
said this, which is like
yo, the streets don't
fuck with you anymore.
- [Charlamagne] Yeah.
- Right?
- [Charlamagne] Word up.
- Got it?
- [Charlamagne] Yeah.
- In business world I want
the streets to fucking love me
more than life yet I want to be
the fancy businessman that's on
the cover of Time magazine.
Got it?
- [Charlamagne] Absolutely.
Clearly make a lot of money
or have made a lot of money.
But not once have I thought to
myself money is your motivation.
- I want legacy.
You're right, I made more
money than you know...
You're right. You've sniffed me out.
The people that know me
the best realize money
is the last thing I care about.
- [Charlamagne] Yeah.
- Look, I want it.
- [Charlamagne] But
you don't talk about it.
- Look, I want to
buy the New York Jets.
I'm not going to win
it on my charisma.
- [Charlamagne] Yeah.
- I'm going to need money but I
think when you look for money
you can become rich,
when you look for
legacy or fucking up
the game which I love doing.
I grew up in the wine business,
I built one of the largest wine
retailing companies out in
Jersey called Wine Library.
I didn't want money.
I wanted to change the
wine industry forever, right?
The skills the fact of the
matter is you got to have the
skills and you get
that from the dirt.
And the dirt is so important.
Everybody wants the clouds.
Everybody wants the big dreams.
Everybody wants
the big picture.
Everybody wants the
things that drives you.
It's fun to be romantic about
the clouds, what you're driven
by, where you're trying to go,
the overall picture, the macro,
the micro. The micro is the
gateway to the macro.
By living in the dirt
you can finally get to
the clouds one day.
And so I'm just a
very big fan of dirt.
I love dirt more
than most people.
As a matter of fact, DRock I was
in a documentary called "Dirt".
A movie.
Literally in my IMDb there is a
reference to me being in "Dirt"
the movie so use that DRock.
And so the reason I'm so happy
and so comfortable and so at
peace is as of this second I've
achieved my bucket list item
which is I am in pursuit of
buying the New York Jets.
Not owning the New York Jets.
And I implore so many of you to
really give a thought about how
do you create a game in your
life that you've actually won
before you've even started it.
I like doing that.
I used to think
about that a lot.
It's funny, even I'm improv'ing
this article right now,
I haven't talked
about this in 15 years.
I used to talk a lot to
Brandon and my dad about
winning before it started.
It's kind of how I thought
about VaynerMedia.
VaynerMedia's a huge success
because it won before it started.
I audited the landscape.
I knew that I was the
leader in social media thinking.
I knew that I would drive it and
it's funny even though a lot of
things that I achieved
seem big or complicated,
I'm actually quite conservative.
I actually quite often put
myself in a position to succeed
before it even happened.
Hence there will be no
devastation on my last breath
if I don't own the Jets.
There would only be a
devastation if I didn't go
through the process
of trying to get them.
(light piano music)
- [Ron] The ones who are
successful have this
gutter, dirt work ethic about them.
As you, really, almost lonely.
It's like you have the demeanor
of a king and queen and you have
king and queen value
but you have to
work like a fucking peasant.
Especially in this
fucking industry.
My advice is just don't put your
talents before your work ethic.
You wanna work.
If you fucking 2% talent
then you better work 200%.
You understand?
You want to work way
beyond your talent level.
Think if I keep the music first
which I always try to do and
know who I am.
Know how I came to this game.
Know what I'm really good
at, what my strengths are.
I'm gonna always on the
capitalize on that, you know?
And I believe that it's time.
All these greats are dying now,
we need new greats.
We need new people
that we can look up to.
And I don't have a problem being
one of those people because
I believe, I believe in myself.
And I'm gonna believe I was
supposed to be that leader for
everyone to follow behind.
But I'm gonna be an
example of how to be successful.
Coming here today, meeting you
guys, getting a feel for what
goes on here it just got me
excited, you know,
because I feel like we
can all help each other.
You know?
I know what I can do
and I feel like
I'm gonna need help doing it.
I know not going to be do shit
by myself and I don't want to.
I want as many people that want
to be involved in the shit,
be involved. Tell me
and I will help you.
I feel like more people
involved the better it's gonna be
and the more people you can reach.
You know?
Amen. And that's it.
(laughter)
- [DRock] That was good.
(light music)